first time it's very sad to you
happy new year everybody oh I'll sing it
to myself oh no she walked away I don't
see me this sticky note we are in
Antigua antigua update from last night
what do we do we went dancing we got Oh
New Year's decoration today's news Eve
that's cool we went dancing to watch
some TV we crash we're supposed to sleep
in but Nina's the line went crazy early
oh you cos u times it's not i want to do
in Antigua Antigua so we're gonna try
some food you go to the beach and look
at the stores let me get our steps make
up our steps ok opps Antigua antica
santika Antigua ki quoi tu a
hey we are in Antigua it's Antigua let's
go famous roadie King best roadie in the
area but it's closed we're here to early
hope to come back Lena's tummy starting
we're not going to tell you we're not
telling you guys I'm not telling you
guys I'm just going to go back to the
boat we came back from the boat leanna
had a nap you doing that Oh Nina was
lying down you close your eyes up we're
gonna go get some food it's a relaxed
day it's a relaxed look at the
decorations how they decorated with Nina
this is mine and this is Nina after the
food we're supposed to go back and
potentially relax on a Antigua beach but
instead we relax in the room and slept
for five hours it's a long time anyway
suppose dinner time we gotta go upstairs
shoot some videos for the channel and
then get ready to go eat where we going
three gir lemaitre elevator are we
taking a look at the grammy's stage hi
this is Nina everybody this is Nina we
love her we love her a lot we love her a
lot some will go to 11 okay we love her
she's special she's gonna blow us a kiss
now here comes it comes to kiss there
you go we're sailing away from Antigua
dinner time leave us look all nice and
yummy hello we got hats there you go
happy new year couldn't decide so we're
gonna go check out the show we haven't
gotten a single show since you've been
here someday fine then so we'll see if
the church isn't again over the phone
i'll add the film show work because of
copyright issues so awesome this is all
against the show is done nina want to
look at some liquor this thing happy you
keep actin know sometimes I around
oh I'll see it to myself oh no she
walked away as I was singing the sticky
note I went I went high and like close
my eyes and everything was crazy and you
can we just walked away first I it's a
very sad do you want a little post
dinner snack Nina once more soup lobster
bisque and I'm having vanilla ice cream
with fennel sauce so we came back
quickly to the room because Nina wanted
to remove some makeup it was itching
there or something itchy uncomfortable
whatever and I'm on catching up on some
of my news I just signed about this
worth board offer surfboard for standing
desks which I'm going to check out
pretty cool and the internet is off
doing the plank to doing planks
whitening planks babe so what to full a
to full after she just made us these
insanely huge glasses of rum and coke
which is really rum and coke not coke
and rum this might be why your full side
plank hold it for 35 seconds don't fall
you're turning a bit red okay there's
Nina working it I love my wife there she
is the chaos has begun
okay gun have two hours to go good
morning my name we're in sync mart and
today it was hard getting up this
morning having a late party night
although by an early morning it's not a
fantastic combination but we only have
one day and say Marte and we're going to
make most of it so here we go so it
started off as a little bit cloudy but
it's gettin warmer pads of breaking we
got Nina who believe hoodie windy cold
so we're here on new year's day and most
of the stuff actually hurts to be closed
we're either too early and everything's
closed or everything will be shut down
all the ages of New Year's which isn't
great but we're just taking in the
island we found the store that was open
so browsing you're awesome thank you we
were hoping to find a starbucks here of
all the places probably the best better
than starbucks data McDonald's they have
a hard rock cafe but sadly no sorry Nina
found the makeup star to go into a
favorite thing to shop for and out of
nowhere it's raining from super sunny to
rain just like that it's gonna go to
successive so we're outside the Yoda guy
moving museum which was on our list to
do which is a guy I think you created do
you own a character you have a hand in
the other campus you could see all the
tripadvisor reviews and he had
ninety-four percent plus I'm Hayden is a
huge fan of Star Wars and it's all about
being able to take some videos and buy
something but it's close Nina's crying
we can't see because she has her
sunglasses on which is really crying the
Yoda guy very sad maybe we'll have to
come back we're going to go to the most
authentic restaurant on the boardwalk to
get some quick food
and then continue on with a day here we
are the famous barefoot restaurant
okay breakfast is here what do we have
well those eggs are runny it's Sunday so
many Ronnie eggs okay Nina's gonna eat
those Nina like the runny eggs not a big
fan of the runny eggs where's the Johnny
fish this is the salty fish just salty
fish try that ibis healthy fish that's
that's what we came for and Nina's not
too impressed
honest okay it's not you're not that
shopping and then eat the johnnycake all
right
Oh up hasta hat why we were filming my
hat blew off pie pie hat bai bai hat
inning inning we jump in and get I can't
swim time to learn
this little thank you so we decided to
chill out on the beach name is gonna
pass out for sure
and we're going to relax here for the
rest of the day okay well we had a good
two and a half hours Lena naps I relaxed
I have some good ideas that came to
connect side of the bed and feeling
feeling killed
okay um II haven't got mashed potatoes
gravy butter chicken with rice and pasta
with alfredo sauce Nina's round 1
consists of an insane plate of salad a
huge bowl of soup and an insane amount
of other food I'm hang around one Friday
found one Evans round two partea with
beef and guacamole and sour cream and
shredded cheese in surprise rise round
three is not yours Nina you no one's ice
cream
what are you doing what the heck is that
looks like a big thing of poo looks like
poo what happened look at this so we
came back we natch we fell asleep for
what an hour and then discovered that my
SD card wasn't working properly and so
we went to dinner have a very filling
dinner but I couldn't film the dinner so
mean it took snapshots of the dinner
that we're going to include right now
and we came into the room we came to the
room and we have a bunny tonight